like like i've had
guys in in the nba hit on me i know
they're not trying to wife me no it's
not impressive they do this to everyone
like
like
are you going to wife anyone are they
you don't see them move on from and even
when they're doing it they weren't just
no there's nba wives they just cheat on
them exactly but they no one's special
in that environment are they no i would
say those girls are like special and
they did do something right they're just
willing to put up with it yeah and i
don't think guys and guys and girls
cheating is different like men and women
they don't cheat the same
tell them again
no no because a man can still love a
girl and cheat on her but like i don't
think women can
it's just
yeah i agree with that no
don't get me wrong like but it's a whole
different ballgame for women i feel as
far as she's a whole different kind of
energy and a whole different kind of
bull game
because she's trying to do better if she
cheats on you she thinks she can do
better and she's trying better in what
department
like what whatever you're lacking as a
dude
as amanda's never been cheated on i'm
very interested in this and i would know
if i had i'm not saying it from a place
of you know arrogance i'm saying it from
a place of certainty i've not been
cheated on my shit's official pattern
correct but i'm very interested to hear
this conversation so you're saying when
women cheat they're doing it for a place
of
what they're trying to think they're
gonna level up okay okay so i remember
the day and i'm sure you had this moment
when you realized you have to worry
about the ugly girls too oh absolutely
yeah because because guys no no because
guys will cheat
guys will cheat with a girl they would
never or they will sleep with a girl
they would never be seen in public it
would never be like bring her into
daylight
but but women when we like when we cheat
we look first we're looking for
something our partner doesn't have yeah
so if girls cheat they cheat up maybe
the guy's better looking maybe he has
more money maybe he's better in bed i
don't know what it is something that
will benefit them
yeah but girls aren't just gonna sleep
with a homeless guy that goes up to them
no
and has nothing going for him
unless he's really hot
we're not gonna sleep without again
it's the animal that's what you just
said animals right i said they put it in
animals oh
but no i think it's just that yeah the
caveman in us that animal thing that
urges you know if you it's hard to get
uh control of you have to be
strong-headed to be able to deal with
certain things men are led around by
addicts a lot of the time i generally
think it's in your dna it is
and it's something if you can get
control of that then you can you can
navigate through life very a little bit
i want control over it
they genuinely want to enjoy that
caveman instinct and they want to
control it or reign in it's a primal
urge listen
we were you know hunters and whatever
so i was going to say hunters and
gabriel's got the words from my mouth so
you know we will have that primal urge
we can't help it we are who we are
you know there's a time when if we
bedded several women and slaughtered men
we'd be celebrated in arenas and that's
not that long ago you understand so
that's still in our dna well because
it's harder for guys like you have to
build yourself up in order to do that a
girl just has to exist
you have to breathe so so on that topic
do you guys think body count matters
for men and for women it's a very
different subject isn't it vice versa
for me personally from woman to a man no
but i understand it's very crucial the
other way around yeah very appreciation
like we don't care about their body
count but they can they don't want
someone that's been passed around yeah
they don't
more times they have their higher body
count but as well yeah
that's why
a man should have the higher body count
let's be realistic but
it's not guaranteed now i've been
putting in work from nowadays these
women are putting in work from early
there's young girls talking about some
body count levels that they're like
let's say you're 20. i'm not going to go
into it but there's some 20 year olds
there are some there are some yeah no
but the guys they were on the map the
guys who do you think they didn't no no
that's nice thank you who do you think
they did not say
but it's a it's a again it's a different
kind of team but it's a small percentage
of men so one in three men
under the age of 30 either have not
slept with anyone in a year or more
that's why or are very conditional or
are virgins
so no no so again like we're going back
to it's a very small percentage of men
so when you're saying like oh the men
are wild like that's right you're not
you're not talking about men you're
talking about
the chats like the the the hot guys like
you're talking about five ten percent
i've seen some ugly guys
you see but you have to understand even
even even the guys that you think are
ugly they're getting no no even the guys
that you think are ugly are probably
satisfying like a couple biological
things that women look for so like for
example for example like they're
probably tall they might be ugly or less
attractive but they're probably tall and
the funny thing is the funny thing is
like usually when i see
girls call guys ugly a lot of times they
call guys ugly that i would say facially
have a more symmetrical face than them
yeah i don't even like when people call
people ugly really as a thing so so like
i'll i'll rate people because i i do
this like sort like because i try to get
people on my show right but you can rate
people like one to ten and the way i do
it is like eight like it's a kevin
samuels he had this scale eight to ten
is like model five six is like pretty
cute
and so like a lot of times i'll see
girls like call guys ugly but like i
literally think they're on the same
level yeah
[Music]
i like that a lot
that's interesting
so like even the usually even the guys
that like they call ugly like still
satisfy something because otherwise you
know girls
no girl is going to sleep with the guy
that's broke ugly and that man that
meant that mandy called him sure
he could be the good guy the one that
could be the good guy always ugly man
making sexy money
see it there he could be the good guy
making bread he could be the protector
provider he could be the good guy yeah
but the the problem is